In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for September 21st, on which we commemorate the Holy Prophet
Jonah.
Jonah is one of the twelve minor prophets of the Old Testament.
He was the Son of Amitai of Gathepher near the city of Azotus on the sea coast in the land
of the Philistines.
He lived during the 8th century before Christ, and foretold to King Jeroboam II in the years
788 through 748 BC, the restoration of the kingdom of Israel to its old borders.
The Lord commanded Jonah to go to Nineveh to preach the coming destruction of the city if
its inhabitants did not repent.
Jonah was seized with fear, and knowing that God is gracious and merciful, slow to anger
and abounding in steadfast love, and always ready to change his mind and not punish.
He strongly suspected that the Lord would bring his prophecy to not, and he tried to flee
far from him, taking ship at Japa for Tarshish in Spain.
But God, who is everywhere present and fills all things, sent a mighty tempest so that the
ship was in danger of breaking up.
When the sailors found out that the tempest was due to Jonah, they cast him into the sea,
which immediately became calm.
As he fell into the water, Jonah was swallowed by a huge semonster, and remained in its belly
for three days and three nights, prophetically foreshadowing Christ's sojourn in the
bowels of the earth.
Three days later, at the command of God, the beast vomited out Jonah upon the dry land,
signifying Christ's resurrection.
Jonah then left for Nineveh, and for three days went about the city, proclaiming, yet
forty days, and Nineveh shall be overthrown.
To his great surprise, the people heated his words, repented and proclaimed a general fast
that extended even to their animals, so that God put away his anger and did not punish
them.
Jonah was exceedingly displeased, he blamed God for being merciful, and built himself
a little hut to the east of the city.
God made a castor oil plant grow there to give Jonah the comfort of shade, but, at dawn
next day, a worm attacked the plant and it withered, exhausted by the heat of the sun
and by a sultry east wind.
The prophet asked to die.
God answered that if his servant pitted the plant, that was the thing of a night and a day,
with how much more reason should not the Lord have pity on this city of more than twenty
thousand inhabitants.
In this way, God taught Jonah and all generations that he prefers mercy to justice, and in every
age awaits the conversion of sinners that they may live and not die.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.